[Music]
in 1992 a cargo ship carrying bath toys
got caught in a storm shipping
containers washed overboard and the
waves swept 28,000 rubber ducks and
other toys into the North Pacific but
they didn't stick together quite the
opposite the Ducks have since washed up
all over the world and researchers have
used their paths to chart a better
understanding of ocean currents ocean
currents are driven by a range of
sources the wind tides changes in water
density and the rotation of the earth
the topography of the ocean floor and
the shoreline modifies those motions
causing currents to speed up slow down
or change direction ocean currents fall
into two main categories surface
currents and deep ocean currents surface
currents control the motion of the top
10% of the ocean's water while deep
ocean currents mobilize the other 90%
though they have different causes
surface and deep ocean currents
influence each other in an intricate
dance that keeps the entire ocean moving
near the shore surface currents are
driven by both the wind and tides which
draw water back and forth as the water
level Falls and Rises meanwhile in the
open ocean wind is the major force
behind surface currents as wind blows
over the ocean it drags the top layers
of water along with it that moving water
pulls on the layers underneath and those
pull on the ones beneath them in fact
water as deep as 400 metres is still
affected by the wind at the ocean's
surface if you zoom out to look at the
patterns of surface currents all over
the earth you'll see that they form big
loops called gyres which travel
clockwise in the Northern Hemisphere and
counterclockwise in the southern
hemisphere that's because of the way the
Earth's rotation affects the wind
patterns that give rise to these
currents if the earth didn't rotate air
and water would simply move back and
forth between low pressure at the
equator and high pressure at the poles
but as the Earth's spin
err moving from the equator to the North
Pole is deflected eastward and air
moving back down is deflected westward
the mirror image happens in the southern
hemisphere so that the major streams of
wind form loop like patterns around the
ocean basins this is called the Coriolis
effect the winds push the ocean beneath
them into the same rotating gyres and
because water holds on to heat more
effectively than air these currents help
redistribute warmth around the globe
unlike surface currents deep ocean
currents are driven primarily by changes
in the density of seawater as water
moves towards the North Pole it gets
colder it also has a higher
concentration of salt because the ice
crystals that form trap water while
leaving salt behind this cold salty
water is more dense so it sinks and
warmer surface water takes its place
setting up a vertical current called
thermohaline circulation thermohaline
circulation of deep water and wind
driven surface currents combine to form
a winding loop called the global
conveyor belt as water moves from the
depths of the ocean to the surface it
carries nutrients that nourish the
microorganisms which form the base of
many ocean food chains the global
conveyor belt is the longest current in
the world snaking all around the globe
but it only moves a few centimeters per
second it could take a drop of water a
thousand years to make the full trip
however rising sea temperatures are
causing the conveyor belt to seemingly
slow down models show this causing havoc
with weather systems on both sides of
the Atlantic and no one knows what would
happen if it continues to slow or if it
stopped altogether the only way we'll be
able to forecast correctly and prepare
accordingly will be to continue to study
currents and the powerful forces that
shape them
what about the creatures that adapted to
survive in these swirling seas take a
closer look at some truly fascinating
ocean dwellers with these two animations
[Music]